a famous explorer once said the day
extraordinary and what we do not who we
are
I'd finally set out to make my mark to
find adventure
but instead
adventure found me what we're doing with
lara croft as a character is we're
really trying to establish Juarez of all
human or mortal or believable anna more
empathetic character one eventually
connect to whether you can actually see
go through trials and tribulations well
you can see go you know from an
inexperienced young girl and see her
grow of course of this adventure of the
course of this survival story into
basically a heart of a warrior that we
know and love we're really taking it
back to its roots we're really taking it
in a new direction we're really looking
at the origins and lara croft and
exploring an area of the character and
this this great franchise that has never
been explored before when all seemed
lost
I found a truth and I knew what I must
become some of the things we're doing to
bring the character in the environment
together and making us feel whole is we
repay placing an emphasis on making sure
that the character feels up one and feel
part of the environment you'll see the
character touch interact with the space
around here see it touch the walls
you'll see the camera actually play a
big part in making you feel connected to
her and connected to the environment
we're bringing in very close entire it
just above it yeah we bring it out where
it feels open it wide also through
character performance we see not only
her interaction with the environment
also the effects of the environment her
so her injury acting our ability to
physically communicate what she's going
through in these environments as well as
the voice acting in the dial
all the way always we're actually trying
to find the character worlds together
and really kind of blow those lives the
concept of physics being a very real
life and grounded version of physics
fire water buoyancy weight and mass
manipulation these are all things that
very easy to look into a space and see
that relationships and actually kind of
understand how to put those pieces
together and physics being a real star
for us in this game you know that's some
of the things we're trying to do to make
sure that as a player you really feel
connected to this world and it feels
something that you can actually
understand the progress room
you